Every single one of you has something that you're good at.
Every single one of you has something to offer.
And you have a responsibility to yourself to discover what that is.
That's the opportunity an education can provide.
Maybe you could be a great writer.
Maybe even good enough to write a book or articles in a newspaper,...
...but you might not know it until you write that English paper,...
...that English class paper that's assigned to you.
Maybe you could be an innovator or an inventor.
Maybe even good enough to come up with the next iPhone, or the new medicine, or vaccine,...
...but you might not know it until you do your project for your Science class.
Maybe you could be a mayor, or a senator, or a supreme court justice,...
...but you might not know that until you join student government or the debate team.
And no matter what you want to do with your life,...
...I guarantee that you'll need an education to do it.
You wanna be a doctor, or a teacher, or a police officer?
You wanna be a nurse, or an architect, a lawyer, or a member of our military?
You're gonna need a good education for every single one of those careers.
You cannot drop out of school and just drop into a good job.
You've got to train for it, and work for it, and learn for it.
And this isn't just important for your own life and your own future.
What you make of your education will decide nothing less than the future of this country.
The future of America depends on you.
What you're learning in school today will determine whether we as a nation...
...can meet our greatest challenges in the future.